good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that great thing that you have
inside you explode out into the world
and have a big impact so to help you on
your journey today's message is find the
right balance over to you Dwayne the
rock Johnson oh yes I get up super early
general I have this thing where I like
beating the Sun up not just in terms of
what Sun comes up I have to get up and
how do I do it it's just important to
find balance and I try and do things
really that I really enjoy doing and a
lot of times you know it's like in life
right life brings like drama and you're
gonna deal with this person and make
your relationship here do all these
things you try and just kind of balance
them out as best I can I got a great
team around me by the way who really
really helps me well and helps me allows
for me to come in and work 12 hours a
day 14 hours a day get up at 3 o'clock
in the morning send out an Instagram
video where I'm talking to my cardio
machine like a crazy maniac requires a
lot of around so you guys might be
watching this clip and thinking waking
up at 3 in the morning is not a really
balanced life and I want you to really
take a pause there if that's what you're
thinking because you should not be
judging what somebody else's version of
a balanced life looks like you've seen
their life through your lens and saying
that's not right that's not balanced
that's wrong stop it
it doesn't matter what Dwayne Johnson
does like if you can use that to inspire
you great what's more important is what
does balance look like for you for him
maybe it is maybe that's a balanced life
I want to wake up 3:00 a.m. every day I
want to beat the Sun up I want to get
all this stuff done that's what a
balanced life looks like to me
great more importantly is what does a
balanced life look like for you you
might want to work eight hours a day and
then do other things with family and
friends and travel and all this other
stuff you might want to work 16 hours a
day and the other things you don't
prioritize as much like what does that
balance life look like for you and then
design a schedule around it
and for me I always have my macro
balance and then my micro balance right
and so in the macro I want to spend time
on my business I love my business I love
making videos I love writing my book I
love doing the things that I'm doing I
love it like every day I'm challenged
I'm excited it's not always perfect
every day but like I love the work that
I do and I want to be a good husband and
I want to be a good father you know and
I want to spend time with Timo right
like the things that are important to my
life I try to fit into a macro calendar
and I genuinely schedule things out and
if I ever feel like something is out of
whack or out of balance it goes right to
my schedule I got a there's something
wrong in my schedule I feel like I'm not
spending enough time with Nina it's not
it's not quality enough time I need to I
need to fix that I go right to my
calendar say okay me the time we need to
do it here we need to do it here we need
to do it here that's what I do in the
macro and the micro you can have a lot
of little changes a lot of little tweaks
a lot little passion projects that that
come and go as an example with my book
I'm on my cruise and I just decided I
want to have my book out I need to
finish my book it's like it's
all-consuming it's obsessive I need to
get this book out I have a date I want
to get it out and a lot of the nights on
my cruise I would be working on the book
and you know be sleep I'd be working my
book you know would go workout at the
gym I'll be working on my book I would
neglect other things in my life so that
I could finish the book and hit my
target and get it out because it was it
was something I need to get done if I
didn't get it done I would regret it I'd
be thinking about the book while working
out or thinking about the book while
doing something else I wouldn't be
sleeping because I'd be thinking about
the book and I got it done and it's
great and luckily I have supportive
people around me who can understand
those micro moments that's not a
long-term sustainable thing you know if
I constantly worked and neglected my
wife my relationship will fall apart if
I constantly worked and neglected my
sleep or neglected my working out and
that neglected eating well my health
would fall apart I can do it for a week
I could do it for two weeks I could do
it for three days or whatever I need to
stay in that zone but I can't do it on
the macro and so it's being flexible
enough in the micro but still
maintaining what your macro schedule
looks like I believe that most people
don't wake up in the zone every day you
can get yourself there certain energy
level you can get yourself to the point
where like today I'm doing
I wanted to be meaningful one to be
impactful I'm gonna go make a positive
impact somehow but you're not always in
the zone not every day you're in the
zone and for me when I feel like I'm in
the zone I have to go out and do amazing
work and I throw everything else aside
to make that thing happen because what
I'm gonna make happen in the zone is
gonna be amazing it's gonna be
life-changing right that's the real gold
and luckily again the people around me
understand that and we adjust and then
after that thing is done I have to go
and spend more time writing I spend more
time with Nina more time with Hayden and
more time on my health because I've
neglected that and things slowly start
to erode so I got to build up that
strength again so I would encourage you
not to really care so much about what
somebody else's version of balance looks
like figure it out for yourself figure
out on a macro scale what does a
balanced life look like for you how much
time do you want to work how much time
do you want to spend doing other things
your big goals what you want to
accomplish as a human being a career
personal everything making sure that the
daily activities that you have map
towards achieving your goals the things
that you're doing on a daily basis help
you accomplish the big goals that you
set for yourself do that in the macro
and then in the micro you'll have
moments you have days you have hours
where like you really need to go off and
do this thing and I would encourage you
to go off and do that thing and let the
other things slide a little bit
as long as one you're not fooling
yourself and say like oh this email like
I'm so within the zone on making this
email right like you're fooling yourself
and - as long as you don't stay there so
long that the other things start to
crumble if you're staying there too long
you have to adjust the macro if you
really want to work like if I really
want to work on my book and I can't get
it done in that like narrow window that
I want to get done and I'm pulling
things making sacrifices short term to
make this thing happen but I need to
keep going and it's this is gonna be
like weeks and months then I have to
pull it out of the micro and move it to
the macro make time in my schedule to
make that big goal
so the question date today is I'm
curious what is a balanced the schedule
look like for you how do you balance
your life what's an ideal version that
you want to work towards I'd love to
hear from you
please share it down the comments below
I also want to give a quick shout out to
Dante Kors Dante thank you so much for
picking up a couple of my book gear one
word I really appreciate the support me
and
you enjoyed the so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much loved
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot event spresso
[Music]
both Ryan and I our at times I want to
say envious but but we look at other
people like you take Kendrick Kendrick
is a rapper Kendrick is in the studio
right now
I guarantee it he's not thinking about
you know that the merge design that we
have right now isn't fitting on it on a
tank top the way that it should it's
true and and that's a it's a blessing
and a curse you know we we both are have
we are the output in terms of anything
creative it it's a music video if it's
directing if it's writing a treatment if
it's if it's you know being a character
in the music video it we are everything
same thing with their merge same thing
with just the ideas that we have full
circle in terms of running a business so
that's taking away time that we could be
working on our specific grass producing
and rapping so I think that it's a
balance we both enjoy business we both
enjoy being holistically creative that's
a fulfilling thing I don't want to be in
the studio every single day all the time
I want to be picking fonts I want to be
you know with Ryan color editing a music
video that's something that we both
enjoy so it's a balance and I think that
we haven't we wear enough hats that we
can kind of bounce around and be
inspired but it comes at a sacrifice I
got great advice from you know one of
the people that totally fascinates me is
Bob Iger he's the CEO of the Walt Disney
ABC world and he so his job is so weird
to me because he is in charge of
everything from like a Disney cruise to
George Stephanopoulos ABC News like he
thought he took like a theme park to
scandal like every all of that falls
into the ABC Disney family and I asked
him and it was very helpful to me I
asked him a few months ago like how do
you decide what you're gonna work on in
a day and he said something so valuable
to me so I'm gonna share with you guys
he said 80% of his time he tries to
think about where can I have impact
where am I going to make a difference in
the day today so it may not usually be
Disney cruises but sometimes it needs to
be because
the crews business has been doing what
the cruise business is doing or that's
not quoting him by the way but there you
know it main sometimes it's a Broadway
show that's about to open sometimes it's
they eat the ESPYs because ESPN that's
where his focus needs to be so it's
really about like where can I have
impact today and the other two where am
I needed the other 20% is what brings me
joy you know so there are certain movie
projects that fall under the ABC disney
world that bring him joy or certain
shows are certain you know an opening of
a park or there are certain things that
bring him that just fill him up that
fall in his work responsibilities and I
just really tried I've tried to bring
that with me because you know it's
important for us to remember the joy in
what we do it's important to be
effective in our workplace but it's
important to cultivate the moments that
just bring us joy because that's how
we'll shine in our in our lives as
professionals you know so you were an
actor whose philosophy is to work or to
wait are you more of a like I'm not
going to do anything until I find the
right thing or you're just like I should
be working in a little bit of a
workaholic but but I can't but I need to
I feel like I like to take my time I
want to be able to select what I should
do I like to explore try to explore
different things different types of of
experiences but movies select you and by
that I mean a director and a script
they are the ones that are gonna throw
the party and you want to be you want to
go to the best party you know we used
the metaphor of a party for a movie so a
good director and a interesting story
will always you know dominate the
choices that I make or control the
choices that I make because if right now
is a great director with an interesting
script comes to me and wants me to do a
character that might not be a huge
stretch but to be involved with a what a
team movies are not made alone team is
teamwork that always will be like a
exciting and might take first place a
good team might take first place but I
like to take my time but but I like to
work too so you know there's a good
balance you know just keep a good
balance
I don't think waiting to sometimes it's
good to wait because you get exhausted
after doing movies you know you're kind
of like you know you I give it give it a
lot of energy so I'm kind of like
exhausted but but you know a balance you
know might wait for a little bit and
then do one to two movies almost back to
back if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you or that
sums you up or that would be like a
little beacon hey believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details